if I'm getting fast food I want to just
greasy and nasty this gave me the nasty
stuff I really like jack-in-the-box I
don't think I've ever had anything
healthy from jack-in-the-box I get the
same thing every time I go I used to
love jack-in-the-box my first moved to
LA I was broke and just kept eating the
mozzarella cheese sticks and the stuffed
jalapeno it was the closest fast-food
restaurant to where I grew up and I've
had it too many times I feel like I
there's nothing I haven't had I hope
that they have some healthy options yeah
that would be super helpful if you do
feel like you need to go to a fast-food
restaurant at least you can then choose
how the options once you're there it's
pretty good oh this is pretty big too
you wanna trade yeah sure hurry up why
is that why what happened well it kind
of has a lid
no we just go for it
this is really salty anything
I think that's how they're getting taste
in there they've put a bunch of salt on
it how is the chicken it's not bad
I don't eat more it tastes like a fajita
you sound real unsure if it's good or
not it's not you know the best Mexican
food I've ever had would you like to try
this ham delicacy yeah everyone's right
every back trade my back I mean it's
just like a hamburger and instead of a
burger they just put this egg on it and
nothing else so like it's fine it's good
cuz you're a vegetarian I mean they're
all money so like it's good that there's
an option for me to be able to get in
the morning for me personally I'm just
like not a big egg person well I love
breakfast Jax there's nothing wrong with
practice Jack it's pretty heavy
looks hefty EFT I wouldn't order that
but I would definitely order this
anytime I'm the opposite this one's
great I like this one so much more than
like the egg hockey puck in that one
hockey puck is the best part man if I
was feeling like I didn't want to eat
your job back I got a hundred was it
really and this one I really liked but
it still kind of feels like fast-food
350 calories like I feel like I'd rather
go with a different option maybe they
should hire me because I feel like we
could have done way better with this we
could have done some whole-grain bread
but some freaking like that it seemed to
me like those veggies if I were trying
to be health-conscious
I would probably pick these I wouldn't
go to a fast-food restaurant for yeah
he's barking up the wrong tree yeah my
opinion on Jack a box is definitely
changing knowing that they have these
other options and stuff like that is
definitely change and I would be more
willing to go in and see that they do
have options yeah I think that's the
thing like if I were there for whatever
reason this is a great option and I like
it
and it's not just what you think of Jack
in the books
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]